Bonjour à tous, curieuses et curieux ! Vous aussi, ça vous déprime quand vous êtes tout seul, isolés
chez vous, à ne voir personne quand vous êtesmalades ?
Un virus apparaît et tout est dépeuplé...
Surtout pour des êtres sociaux comme nous, les humains... Mais d'ailleurs, et vous dans
la nature, ça se passe comment ?
- Une équipe descientifiques s'est intéressée au comportement
de certains groupes d'animaux sociaux frappéspar des maladies, et apparemment, en cas de crise,
il vaut mieux être malin comme un singe... Ah, jesens que cet épisode va nous filer la banane !
Les humains sont des animaux sociaux, on le voitau quotidien : nos vies, nos cultures, nos modes
de communication sont basés sur l'échange, le contact et l'interaction, et nous ne sommes
pas les seuls ! Certaines espèces de fourmis, de poissons, d'abeilles et même de homards
sont aussi des animaux sociaux ! Des scientifiquesétudiant les macaques se sont rendus compte que ces
animaux tissent des réseaux de relations socialescomplexes, permettant la diffusion d'informations
au sein d'un groupe. Figurez-vous que les macaquespeuvent se partager de vrais savoir-faire entre
générations d'un seul groupe. On a observé qu'ilsétaient capables de se transmettre des techniques
de nettoyage de patates douces, mais aussi deshabitudes, voire des traditions : une vraie culture.
Donc, autant vous, dire la distanciation sociale, à la base c'est pas vraiment leur truc non plus.
-OH ! Tu t'es lavé les mains avant de m'épouiller ?
-Et pourtant,des scientifiques ont étudié le comportement de
ces mêmes animaux sociaux, ayant observé quedans la nature, ils étaient capable d'appliquer
des solutions simples et efficaces en cas demaladie dans un groupe. Attention, spoilers : vous
n'allez pas voir des homards se faire la bise-que pourse dire bonjour, ou des poissons faire les gestes
barrière de corail !
Par contre, vous allez bienvoir des singes faire de la distanciation sociale.
Chez les mandrills, les scientifiques se
sont rendus compte qu'en cas de maladie
dans un groupe, c'est la distanciation socialequi prime pour protéger l'ensemble du groupe ;
et chez d'autres singes, comme les macaques, uneéquipe de scientifiques a réussi à modéliser et
observer directement l'impact de la présencede ces agents pathogènes dans le réseau, via
la modélisation du groupe. Ici en bleu, un
groupe de primates sains. On remarque en rouge
un individu malade, et lorsque la contaminations'étend, le groupe réagit en s'éloignant et en
isolant les primates contagieux pour protégerle groupe et contenir la maladie. Eh oui, on va
quand même pas apprendre à un vieux singe àfaire de la distanciation sociale ! Et chez
les insectes aussi, ça fourmille de solutions encas de maladie. Les scientifiques ont administré
un parasite chez certaines fourmis d'un groupe,et ils ont alors observé que celle-ci adoptaient
certains comportements étonnants pour s'adapter
et pouvoir continuer à échanger des informations,
sans utiliser le contact direct entre elles ! Ilsont remarqué que les fourmis malades s'auto
plaçaient en quarantaine, et que les fourmis sainesutilisaient des gestes barrières : plus question
de se toucher avec les antennes. Pour communiquer,elles utilisent des phéromones et forment un cercle
barrière autour de la reine, pour la protéger.
-hophop hop, jeune fille, toi tu passes pas.
-Laissez-moi passer, c'est juste un p'tit rhume, promis !
-Et ça nes'arrête pas là : les scientifiques ont découvert
que ces comportements sont adoptés chez un tas d'espèces du règne animal, comme un genre de règle
universelle pour se protéger. Alors, pourquoi nepas s'en inspirer, puisque nous sommes aussi des
animaux sociaux ? Finalement, notre compréhensionhumaine moderne de la propagation des pathogènes
et de leur gestion a une histoire de moinsde deux siècles, alors que l'évolution et la
nature ont utilisé des centaines de millionsd'années pour affiner des solutions à ce défi
crucial, alors faisons leur confiance ! La natureest une source d'inspiration incroyable, alors
que vous soyez tendance macaques, fourmis ouhomards, soyez stratégiques pour vous et tous les
autres : tous les moyens sont bons pour seprotéger, et pour protéger la nature aussi.
Si toi aussi tu aimes les animaux sociaux et la bisque de homard, abonne-toi !